well the first time the task force
presented its predictions of where this
pandemic may be heading saying this
could now be done because of a more
detailed flow of information from across
the country the scientists say the virus
could kill between 100,000 and 240,000
Americans but without efforts like
social distancing countermeasures like
shut downs the toll could go far higher
they've modeled a worst-case scenario of
1.5 million to 2.2 million deaths so
what we're gonna see in that so we gotta
brace ourselves in the next several days
to a week or so we're gonna continue to
see things go up we cannot be
discouraged by that because the
mitigation is actually working and will
work a Samba president Trump said the
mitigation measures will a matter of
life and death I want every American to
be prepared for the hard days that lie
ahead we're gonna go through a very
tough two weeks and then hopefully as
the experts are predicting is I think a
lot of us are predicting after having
studied it's so hard you're gonna start
seeing some real light at the end of the
tunnel but this is going to be a very
painful very very painful two weeks in
the city at the epicenter of the
pandemic the rate of infection continues
to rise the number of hospital
admissions in New York City increased by
12% in the last 24 hour period and in
Central Park a field hospital will be
ready by late Wednesday everyone
everyone is subject to this virus it is
the great equalizer I don't care how
smart how rich how powerful you think
you are I don't care how young how old
this virus is the great equalizer nearly
190,000 people have now tested positive
for the virus in all 50 states plus
Washington DC and as the models show
this number is increasing by the hour
Mike Hanna al Jazeera Washington